can you wear unhealthy clothes that's
one of the questions you left on a
recent video of mine I'm answering that
and so many more from my comment section
right now huge thanks to butcherbox for
sponsoring this video stay tuned to see
how you can get a free turkey with your
first box people
how can I prevent my nipples from
chafing on my shirt when I run you know
what's funny I've never in my life had
this be a problem maybe I'm not running
enough but I feel like with boxing on a
given week I'm running 20 miles a week I
feel like I should have experienced this
I don't maybe I have chaffless nipples
if you are truly having an issue I've
heard Band-Aids do a good trick on this
there's also like some anti-static spray
you could put on your body I've never
had a patient with this I've never had
it it's interesting that so many people
do talk about it is it bad to wear
Converse Chuck Taylors when I do squats
at the gym so many lifters say they're
great shoes for lifting but when they
aren't sold in sport shoe stores well
correct me if I'm wrong these shoes were
initially a basketball shoe like back in
the day I do think they're great because
they're supportive for lifting and they
also have like very flat sole I do think
there are more Sports specific shoes
that you can use to lift but I've worn
them before and I've had good success
lifting is it bad to fall asleep
listening to something only when it's
your significant other they might get
upset but if you're using like a white
noise machine it's great what I don't
like falling asleep to is music music
that changes in intensity and TV shows
or movies why because if your brain is
getting a steady stream of information
of sound it's going to do fine and
you'll be able to fall asleep but if
you're starting to get low sound with a
big explosion that's going to wake you
up have something that's on faintly in
the background as white noise great
anything else not a big fan my cat
refuses to use the litter box can you
help
you want me to have a one-on-one talk
with your kitty I have no idea never had
a cat don't even know really how you
teach a cat to use a litter box if you
want to let me know in the comments I'll
improve my cat knowledge why does skin
grow back from a minor cut but a limb
won't grow back if it's cut off why do
some body parts grow back and some don't
it really depends on the initial type of
stem cell in a given area bone heals and
grows back skin heals and grows back
Nails heal and grow back as long as
you're not damaging that base layer
there but full regeneration of most
things don't happen even for a liver to
regenerate part of itself it needs to be
there like some of it needs to be there
yo doc I keep seeing these ads for
posture correctors on my Ig do these
really work should I get one I need to
see the evidence on them in like a
rigorous trial to see what it means when
they say they work if that doesn't lead
to decreased pain and Improvement in
range of motion then the thing itself
fails now for me I would much rather get
you in a play place where we strengthen
your core muscles your back muscles your
stabilizers we get you in a healthy
range of motion where you don't need a
posture corrector I think that's one of
those gimmicky tools at least for now
that you probably don't need why does it
feel better to sleep on the cool side of
the pillow I think this has something to
do with your body temperature your core
body temperature dropping when you do go
to sleep like a lot of those memory foam
mattresses tend to gather and store heat
so much so that when you're laying on
one side you just like feel that heat
bouncing back at you that can disrupt
your sleep because your body tends to
stay cool in the early part of the night
so that's why I think we like the cool
side of the pillow I like it mostly
because it's how I grew up I always hung
out with the cool pillows in school
this is one of the hardest questions but
here goes which is more important the
heart or the brain bro the heart can't
do anything without the brain you know
when they say someone's all heart I say
that's the brain being humble and not
taking credit where it's due is it okay
to never wear underwear I would
recommend it just because like bodies
have all sorts of discharges and stuff
and it's going to get on your clothes
like you don't want to lift up your leg
and like flash everybody genitals might
be more sensitive to the chafing of like
jeans in certain pants protect your junk
that's what I say could you do a video
about if essential oils can actually
help you that would be a very short
video because it would just be like this
essential oils sometimes smell good
check out this video why do we feel the
need to stretch when we wake up in the
morning well Lynn because you've been
immobile for a while and a lot of times
you've had pressure on certain parts of
your body for extended period of time so
naturally it feels good to stretch and
get that blood going get those muscles
warmed up in order to face the day and
that's recommended do you have any
favorite Rush food you remember from
growing up pilmeni my favorite food as a
kid borsch close second favorite and pin
Mania are essentially a Russian raviolis
but so good doc settle this once and for
all is chess a sport it's competitive it
burns a lot of calories yeah I think
it's a sport if we're gonna call Esports
a sport chess is a sport God dang it oh
I don't know why I got my football coach
in her football coach out of me on that
one back to the questions in just a
second but first I want to talk to you
about butcherbox the holidays are coming
up and I couldn't be more excited for
all that delicious holiday food
especially post boxing match thanks to
butcherbox I'll be enjoying deliveries
of incredible Meat and Fish right to my
door recently I've been enjoying their
Alaskan sockeye salmon which is not only
delicious but packed full of nutrients
it's seriously so good butcherbox makes
sure that their high quality food is
better for me the farmers the animals
welfare and our planet that's really
important for me you can choose the
delivery frequency too so you get
exactly the foods you and your family
love all in an eco-friendly 100 percent
recyclable box they also make the order
process really easy curate your own box
with whatever Cuts you want or you can
save the time and leave the curation up
to them for a fun surprise instead
here's the best part sign up right now
and new members will receive a free 12
to 14 pound turkey plus 10 off their
first box when you use the promo code 10
turkey just in time for the holidays not
to mention shipping is always free too I
think it's a pretty good deal so visit
the link in my description to get
started with your first order and enjoy
some of that delicious turkey this
holiday season all right let's get back
to some more questions hey Dr Mike is it
true that wearing the wrong shoes or
clothes can actually hurt your body are
there other things I should avoid
wearing if I'm actually trying to stay
healthy you go this is such a good
question I've actually made videos about
this topic in the past clothes do impact
your health for example women that wear
high heels for way too long periods of
time for many years can actually develop
some deformities in their feet a bony
deformity on the back of their heel
called a haglong's deformity also known
as a pump bump where it could actually
lead to Achilles tendinitis or other
types of bursitis you can develop
bunions a neuroma inside your foot and
all these are painful conditions that
usually if you continue wearing heels
we'll need surgery and know that heels
don't just impact your feet they impact
everything above as well because it
changes your gait it changes your
balance your stride so you get knee pain
hip pain low back pain Etc but it's not
limited to just heels it's stuff that
you wear on your body too like we
athletes love compression gear and yes
when you get all sweaty it doesn't
matter if you're wearing cotton or a
polyester compression gear if you don't
get out of it it's going to be a problem
for your skin but compression gear
presents a very unique big problem in
that compression gear tends to pull the
oils from your skin into it so it kind
of over time prevents your skin from
being able to breathe with all that
compression and as a result you can form
acne on your skin folliculitis even
inter-trigo into the crevices within
your body I recommend getting out of
those clothes as quickly as possible and
washing them very thoroughly because if
you ever had a gym bag with some of that
polyester gear in it stinks because the
type of bacteria that eat the oils from
your skin that's trapped inside that
gear release a really foul smell and
it's different than cotton because
cotton doesn't absorb the oil it absorbs
the water so if you leave cotton on for
too long there's like a chance of fun
fungal infections mildew if you don't
let it dry but it's just water so it
doesn't smell as bad it has a slightly
different odor to it that being said for
women who also wear shapewear that can
also be problematic if you're putting a
lot of pressure on your abdomen you
could actually worsen symptoms of acid
reflux because you're putting pressure
on the abdomen it can cause that acid to
come back into the esophagus big problem
for guys who love wearing neckties I'm a
Thai guy I love wearing ties but if you
wear the tie too tight there's actually
research that's been done that shows
wearing a tight tie will decrease the
amount of brain blood flow think about
that if you're going to a meeting and
you want to be sharp you need maximal
blood flow so loosen up those ties maybe
ease up on that shapewear because it can
present a true problem oh one this is
about to become a whole video on clothes
but if you wear very tight compression
like shorts or shapewear on the bottom
of your body you can develop a condition
called moralgia parasthetica you could
put so much pressure on the nerve that
gives sensation to your anterior thighs
where you feel like numbness and
tingling and burning in the thighs just
from wearing that compression and
cutting off putting pressure on that
nerve God close health so interrelated
who knew maybe I'll do a whole video on
that mental and physical effects of your
clothes can you explain what causes
kidney stones I've passed over 50 in a
year and because of the pandemic my
Hospital won't see me so I'm left to
just take pain relief and move on 50
kidney stones in one year is telling me
that something is going on in your body
that is outside of your control that
needs urgently to be addressed and you
need to address it with a urologist to
find out what condition you have that's
predisposing you to so many stones being
formed because my suspicion is if you
are simply an individual who ate a
specific diet and was dehydrated very
often you would not form that many
stones so to me it tells me that there
might be a metal metabolic condition
kidney condition even an anatomical
condition where urine flow is not
passing in the way that it's normally
supposed to occur throughout your
urinary system and as a result that's
causing stones to form is it safe to go
in a hot tub every day I mean like I
don't see the harm in it as long as that
hot tub is maintained and you don't have
like a rash or any other illness just
dry off after it don't stay for too long
and don't overheat hot tubs can be
problematic if you have like a heart
condition because they get you warmed up
and when you get warmed up your body's
has to kick your heart into higher gear
to beat faster to cool off also there is
something known as hot tub folliculitis
where you can get an infection of your
hair follicle from a bacteria known as
pseudomonas looks painful feels painful
sometimes have you ever been told off by
a nurse for doing something dumb
absolutely maybe not so much recently
but definitely in my training days I
made mistakes all the time in New York
City when I was working at a level one
Trauma Center if you mess up they'll
shove you out of the way and start doing
it themselves like when I was first
learning how to do blood draws I wasn't
that great at them and I had to learn
from people who are better most of the
time they were nurses why does swaying a
baby put it to sleep it probably has
something to do with the movements that
it's experienced when the mom was moving
around and it was in utero when you have
of swaying you also have a constant
signal to the brain when you have a
constant signal to the brain whether
it's audio movement that is relaxing to
us whether we're talking about white
noise or we're talking about swaying a
baby I think all of that is pacifying
just from different variables like one
is from audio one is for movement Etc
Yao Ming 2.0 Dr Mike why do some people
have a dark neck and how do you get rid
of it what you might be asking about is
a condition called acanthosis [ __ ]
cans which is a darkening of your skin
that can happen with certain medical
conditions most notably diabetes
mellitus where you have poor control of
your blood sugar because of a
malfunction related to insulin that
being said it could be something as
simple as you don't wear sunblock and
you're exposed to sunlight on the back
of your neck and not the front so like
it really is important that you do a
thorough history and physical before you
just go start ordering tests what are
your thoughts on medical professionals
using their place of work to make a
social media content would you as a
patient feel comfortable a doctor who
was on social media and used a practice
you were visiting as your studio so to
speak well it depends on how they're
using it are they using it respectfully
to educate without making anyone feel
uncomfortable and still respecting
everyone's privacy if so why not I would
be excited to go there because I know
what that doctor or that practice stands
for I actually get kind of an inside
look on how they work and it gives me
insight into their relationships and if
I know that they're all close with the
staff that kind of makes me feel at ease
what are some alternatives to therapy
it's not for everyone there has to be
other options right well first of all
there are different types of therapy
family therapy DBT CBT but really the
ultimate thing that decides success in
therapy is your connection to your
therapist there's all types of other
therapies Equine Therapy animal therapy
music therapy that can be used in
specific situations but it's always
important to make that decision with the
help of a mental health professional or
a medical doctor should I wear gloves
when I lift weights you you can go in
many directions here Bailey some people
for aesthetic reasons will choose to
wear gloves they want to prevent
calluses from forming I think the callus
is beneficial as long as it's a healthy
callus meaning that it's not too big
it's not overly dry because what happens
is if it gets really big and overly dry
it can totally rip off and then you have
no padding at all for the weight so you
need to be smart and in some instances
maybe wear gloves or even they have some
of these grips where you could just like
put on a grip and you don't have a full
glove therefore you're not like
retaining all that moisture on your
whole hand but only on the Palmer
surface what's a nice gift to give a
doctor or nurses or other hospital staff
after an Extended Stay I think the rule
is medically ethically speaking it has
to be under thirty dollars or something
that's the guideline set by professional
organizations making a nice meal for
them some cookies or an inexpensive
bottle of wine if you know they like
wine if you're my patient don't give me
anything just stay happy and healthy and
keep working on yourself
click here to check out my reaction to
the Survival show naked and afraid a lot
of things go wrong and remember to sign
up for butcherbox now to get a free 12
to 14 pound turkey in your first box as
always stay happy and healthy
[Music]